Kylie Jenner nervous about motherhood
and what Caitlyn really thinks about her
youngest being pregnant plus Chrissy
Teigen on how little Luna is getting
ready to be a big sister and which of
Nick Jonas's exes got his heart rate
pumping just when you thought we were
done talking about these Dane
kardashian-jenner babies only eats he
has exclusive new details on Kylie
Jenner who will soon be a mom to a
newborn baby just like her sister Kim
though Kylie has been pretty m.i.a since
sources says she's also expecting a girl
today a Kardashian source tells et she
is excited about this new chapter and
has been taking a break from the
spotlight to prepare for her new life as
a mom we're told Kylie has been enjoying
shopping for clothes and furniture for
the nursery and we even spotted a crib
being delivered to her house and Hidden
Hills our source adds Kylie has had her
moments of being nervous but she knows
she has the best teachers to guide her
through being a great mother her own
mother and sisters I think she is a very
strong and I think that the strength
that she has as a woman and an
entrepreneur and a business person and
everything that she's got going on she's
really I think equipped to handle
whatever comes her way
I'm so proud of that kid she's a good
good girl with a big heart but get this
the source also revealed the one family
member who wasn't too happy at first
about Kylie being pregnant was her dad
Caitlyn Jenner Caitlyn apparently wasn't
keen on Kylie being a young mother and
she's quote hesitant about Kylie's
boyfriend the baby's father rapper
Travis Scott still the source adds
Caitlyn knows kylie is an adult now and
can make her own decisions so there you
have it all right well let's talk about
some more baby shall we eat II was just
with Christy Teegan who was expecting
her second child with John Legend she
told us they're gonna keep the
gender a secret for now but she did
reveal how their two-year-old Luna is
preparing to welcome another legend into
the house his moon excited to be she is
so excited she actually she's not her
little baby doll now that she's been
really taking care of him I just
Reverend it's hard though because she's
definitely jealous of John and I or I
don't know how to say it but she just
she's so protective of John and when we
kiss she gets very she like looks from
no matter where she wherever she is
she's like you see her little dark eyes
a little scary so I'm a bit nervous -
you know you I think the balance is hard
I mean you know you want to be able to
give one so much attention and shower
them with love and affection and but
then you have a little baby - and
that'll be rough to balance but I'm
excited to figure it out cuz hopefully
we won't stop it - and then we'll be on
our way - good one Todd Phil you heard
that right John and Chrissy apparently
want even more babies after their kid
comes who is due this spring by the way
all right tonight all eyes will be on
the pregnant working mom as she and LL
Cool J go live with a special lip sync
battle Michael Jackson tribute to help
launch the paramount Network alright
switching gears now to Nick Jonas who is
not expecting a baby but he is dishing
on his famous exes strapped in for BBC
Radio One's running gag yesterday
breakfast show host Nick Grimshaw went
all out to get Nick's heart rate to go
up but Nick had no idea a surprise
message from Selena Gomez who he dated
in 2008 would get his pulse racing as
she recalled their date gone wrong hello
Nicholas it is some legal mess don't
need to say my full name with you but it
is so I know what you're doing and I
would like to I would like to remind you
of a time where we all went to Central
Park together Central Park was really
beautiful as I've said my first time
caught right how it's gonna it's 19
we're in Central Park and we were very
private about our relationship and she
was unhappy that her her Central Park
history was ruined by the fact that I
walked about 20 feet away from her even
though they're taking pictures of us and
obviously we're together I was like be
better understand
another jilted ex Miley Cyrus who he
dated before Selena it's been long
rumored Miley wrote 7 things about Nick
and though she never confirmed the track
was about him he said there is a hidden
message in the video she's wearing a dog
tag in this thing guys that I gave her
right when I was 14 - listen my goal in
life is to be that ex somebody writes
about okay anywho that's all I got for
you guys today make sure you guys have
your notifications turned on for the
daily deni because I will be back
tomorrow with the new music Friday jams
like the new Justin maybe a little new
choice of Bond endless possibilities so
I'll see you guys then